i was kind of concerned because for like
three days my dick was purple and black
and blue and looked like it'd been run
over by a semi truck my wife was
obviously a little bit concerned as well
with me experimenting with these fringe
protocols on my genitals and and them
looking pretty bad after the fact
ben greenfield welcome to the show hey
man i forgot my uh i forgot my fake pop
my fake soda you have one but so
unfortunately i now have soda envy fake
soda envy so
you told me when i was on your show i
was drinking a diet dr pepper and you
castigated me yeah uh
for drinking it which has happened a
number of times by both my audience and
you and you told me
you red pilled me on xiv which i liked
because i liked the taste and that it
was zero calorie but then you started
telling me about stuff they've done with
the type of tin or
aluminium that they use in the cans and
a bunch of other stuff what what's so
good about xavier i don't know i don't
know what aluminium is uh in this
country we say aluminum
uh but i i actually interviewed their
founder his weird name i think it's like
patty or something like that um
maybe that's not a weird name in the uk
but it's a it's a weird name here
patty and he filled me in on like the
natural form of stevia that like you
know not all stevia is created equal
some has like maltodextrin and sugars
added to it and so is synthetic and you
know because i like have stevia growing
outside my window here it's just like a
natural stevia leaf that i can use to
sweeten stuff but apparently they use
like a supernatural stevia in it
and they've tested the actual like
liquid contents of the can to show that
the metal isn't leaching out into the
cam shows because when i interviewed him
i put him on the spot about a lot of
this stuff because i'm like okay so it
says natural and calorie-free but let's
get into the details and we just drink
it like some toxic form of something
that's supposedly bandied about it's
healthy and like it kind of passed all
all the uh all the all the checks on
that so this the ben greenfield smell
test says that if you're gonna do
a
calorie-free soft drink xevier is one of
the best yeah it's it's pretty good
because look they do like a ginger beer
that's good for moscow mule that coke
that you're drinking right now is great
for whiskey and coke and the ginger root
beer if you pour that on coconut ice
cream you've got yourself a like a you
know healthy hippie root beer float
so serious
it's a universal [ __ ] you just got back
from a hunt tell me about that
oh i was hunting um in
in malachi which is this crate doesn't
even feel like you're in america it's
like this third world country like no
offense to the people who live in
malachi it's beautiful and the people
there are super cool but it's just like
isolated and it used to be where they
exile lepers like people with uh with
hansen's disease which is like this
sickle cell disorder that results in
like the the skin getting eaten away you
probably heard a leprosy before and they
used to like have a leper colony there
and they do even like like tests on
these lepers and bring in prisoners and
inject them with leprosy to develop
vaccinations and like you know monsanto
bless their hearts are
like the main employer on the island so
they got a bunch of like crazy seed
testing stuff going on there so so
they're almost kind of like shy of the
mainlanders it seems almost as though
that i mean there is good reason
geographic reason to be right it's like
well it's in hawaii um it's one of the
hawaiian islands it's like 10 miles wide
about 30 miles long takes like maybe an
hour to drive across the whole thing
and it's it's like a jungle it's um
like you you flew into jurassic park on
a helicopter as you're coming in there's
waterfalls tumbling down these steep
cliffs going into the ocean and you know
very very few people but a ton of really
good hunting particularly for axis deer
which is considered amongst many hunters
to be like some of the best tasting wild
game meat on the planet matter of fact
yeah you can see in the video i like
that i have hunted access there a few
times i've shot three axis bucks before
that one behind me is uh is one that i
got in texas actually but it actually
tastes really good and they're super
hard to hunt they're like
white-tailed deer which are already a
really smart deer that are pretty
elusive they're like white-tailed deer
on crack like
you you literally
shoot
your arrow from your bow and they can
hear the arrow coming off the string
and i shoot i shoot a pretty heavy
poundage and a pretty fast arrow it's
about 360 foot per second which is
pretty fast for an arrow coming off a
bow and they'll even hear that and by
the time the arrow has reached them
they will either duck or jump
and like try to miss the error
so you know even if you get in on them
it's hard to hit the vitals and it's a
it's a tough hunt i was i was hunting
with my sons my twin 14 year old sons i
was super proud of one of them who just
like sat
like a freaking sniper for eight hours
just covered in camo in the bushes you
know his his scent block on and you know
just
sat side which is hard for a 14 year old
boy you know
and uh and he he shot a deer and got
some venison and i was i was super proud
of him but it was cool cool father-son
experience yeah i just came in on a red
eye yesterday and uh
and here i am baby dude unstoppable i
remember we went to
uh paleo fx in austin we caught up in
paleo yeah a while ago um i noticed then
that you had a uh that necklace on
you've got around your neck what is it
i don't know people just send me [ __ ] to
put on uh right this is this is two it's
it's two things actually that put on the
same necklace which is so i don't know
if it cancels each other out but the one
is called a biogeometry pendant
and
i got it from an organization in egypt
that has studied a lot of the
geometrical shapes built into
many of the pyramidal structures you
know like the like the pyramids in not
only in egypt but all over the world
and they've found there are specific
geometric forms that create what they
call like a negative energy field that's
supposed to be able to
block harmful frequencies or
allow your body to better be able to
handle everything from like negative
energy from people to blasts of emf from
wi-fi routers etc
i'm pretty skeptical of a lot of this
stuff but they've actually got some
studies on things like red blood cell
clumping and the health effects of
certain cities where they've
incorporated these these shapes all over
the city and you can
get them and wear around your neck and i
actually am building home in idaho right
now and i'm having them come out and do
like a full analysis of my land and my
home in idaho to set it all up like feng
shui wise to have these little shapes
like all over the house
i visited one of my friends you may know
him he's a pretty prolific health guy
his name is paul chak i visited his
house and i walked into it i'm like
this feels like a peaceful cave like you
walk in you literally feel
you ever been in one of those little
meditation pods you know like a like a
health centers have now you climb inside
they're almost like sensory deprivation
chambers his house his whole house felt
like that i'm like dude what'd you do
and he said that he did this sacred
geometry analysis and up of all like all
his land his home everything so short
term while i'm waiting for my home and
and the full thing built into my home
i'm wearing the necklace from them then
this other one has come from a company
called lilam quantum tech also pretty
woo and it's got like these capsules
inside of it
you can see i just unscrewed it and dump
them out and
so
basically
this this is super jedi they've got like
all these so apparently certain people
are born with the ability to be able to
do like hands-on healing and distance
healing and
can
kind of like blast their frequencies
across
space to other people and
um
i don't deny that certain people are
born with specific gifts because i've
actually interviewed one guy in illinois
or actually you know he's in ohio dr
anime n-e-m-e-h and he does like prayer
and faith-based healing and some of that
stuff is kind of gimmicky and just like
a way for churches and stuff to make
money you know people walk in and get
slammed in the spirit or whatever baby
but this guy um this guy actually has a
ton of
of like proven cases that he's healed
using like his hands and prayer and
faith and energy and you know you're
probably familiar with like reiki
healing where people do a massage but
they're not actually touching you
they're using the energy from their
hands um
and we know that humans emanate some
kind of energetic frequency but certain
people seem to be able to do it better
and so this company lila quantum tech
they've got like 12
of some of the most powerful healers
from around the globe that they have
put their frequencies into like
wearables and jewelry
imbue them with stuff
yeah and then they ship them to you and
so
this necklace is embedded with all these
frequencies from all these healers
and i don't know it could be placebo but
i feel pretty good when i wear this
necklace so
that's my story and i'm i'm sticking to
it it's probably not as beneficial as
the as the fake dr pepper but it helps
out a little bit
yeah man for someone that is uh an
evidence-based guy i think that's
probably up toward the upper bound of uh
of woo
for you it totally is it totally is but
you know what i i feel good and it works
for me so i'm gonna keep convincing
myself that's doing something plus it
just looks cool yeah it's a conversation
piece i mean you and i just managed to
fill five minutes of dead air talking
about it so it's doing something
we never spoke about all of the stuff
that you did for men's health back in
the day those experiments around
sex and penis injections and prp and
blue pills
believe it or not bros don't sit around
the coffee shop talking about that i
want to talk about your penis ben i want
to talk about what you did to your penis
please
yeah um it's kind of old news
but but we'll talk about it it was men's
health magazine was doing an issue i
think it was january 2018
maybe
uh called
new year new deck
in which they wanted to
have a
magazine devoted to all the things that
a gentleman could do to enhance his
sexual performance or his libido or his
fertility and so
they decided that i would be the perfect
little immersive journalist to do the
story so for six months
i
basically was given the assignment of
chasing down
all the random things that one could do
to enhance one's sexual performance i'm
not a freaking playboy right like i've
i've been married for 20 years i got a
couple of kids you know
you know so it was it was very
interesting i think i was a very
interesting person to to assign this to
and my my dear wife had to be pretty
patient as i'm going around you know
getting my my dick injected with random
substances and trying out different
pills before we'd make love and you know
doing the no ejaculation for a month
just so everything so
a few of the more interesting things was
that um
for example they they had me try
like five or six of the most popular
so-called gas station dick pills which
have all these
all these wonderful superfood
herbs from you know
china and the far reaches of the amazon
and natural supplements island from some
you know one horned goat
and
they uh they package them up and of
course on the label
uh presents you with this idea that
you've got all these crazy superfoods
which i have no clue how they managed to
do that and sell it for three bucks at
the gas station counter but somehow they
do and so uh i took each one of them and
tried each one of them
and of course as you'd
inevitably uh
anticipate
yeah you get clammy hands and a racing
heart and you know not only a giant
gorge dick but just like blood flow to
the whole body like the perfect
pre-workout supplement but kind of like
the pre-workout supplements that got
outlawed because they were giving people
hard tacks and we are we actually did
lab testing on
on all of them and it turns out that the
main two ingredients in every single one
are um ephedra and sildenafil ephedra
being you know potent central nervous
system stimulant that's kind of like an
amphetamine and sildenafil being the
active component of viagra so
when you see a gas station dick pill
with all the purported superfoods and
herbs and blends and everything it's
basically sildenafil and uh and
um and ephedra so
but i mean they they work but i wouldn't
i wouldn't
consider them to be healthy especially
for anyone who has say like um a heart
uh then
the uh the other interesting ones was
like the the no ejaculation you know
where and that was that's more like an
ayurvedic you know ancient you know
eastern practice where you just
basically don't come for a month and
that doesn't mean you know the
intercourse you just don't come so
that i absolutely
hated i was angry i was pent up it's
like again i'm a married man with kids
when i have time to have sex with my
wife i want the full meal deal i want
the full experience and so i would like
it grumpy and i get pent up and i get
like aggressive and i'd have to go lift
weights like you know in the morning
after we'd had sex hard because i felt
like i i had like this this this pent up
energy inside me so i suppose when you
know
there's advice to say like i don't know
ufc fighter or or a tennis athlete or
something to
to do like you know no sex no porn no
masturbation prior to their event i i
think there is something too i think
it's just pent up energy that it creates
i suspect it's probably accompanied by a
rise in testosterone i didn't do a blood
testosterone test but you know it seemed
to work for that but i i didn't like
the whole feeling that i had from that
well the mechanism the mechanism that
it's working on might not be something
quite as complex as the physiology and
the relative levels of your sex binding
hormone globulin and stuff it could just
be that you're a bit pissed off
yeah exactly i think that's the case a
lot of people say well it depletes your
minerals bro and you're wasting all your
zinc and boron and dhea because you need
that to make your sperm and your seed
and the fact is like you need so so few
minerals to make like the teeny tiny
half teaspoon or teaspoon or you know
whatever if if uh if you're a real
performer maybe a tablespoon of sperm
that like there's no way it's going to
deplete you you could you could like
ejaculate every day and not take any
minerals and you'd survive i suspect for
for years on end so it's not like it's
nutrient depleting bro i was in i got to
tell you this story i'm in dubai about
uh a couple of years ago and i was there
with a bunch of friends
just sat in the pool
talking about whatever the [ __ ] we were
talking about one of the guys turns to
us looks me dead in the eyes and he's
like dude
how much do you come
i like
like like the volume what do you mean
precisely my i needed clarification what
do you mean
like the volume of semen that comes out
of me yeah yeah like how much do you
come
i said well what like what do you want
do you want the actual like amount do
you want it on like a percentile he's
like well just like compared with other
guys i said well look i i make it a
purpose of mine to try and avoid
watching other men come as much as
possible if i've made it to that point
in porn when i do see another man come
then i've made an error because i like i
i don't tend to watch that far in but i
was like look if it's percentile press
pause rewind okay skip back 15 minutes
measure look like and also i don't think
that if i was to do that that they're
probably a very representative sample of
men in any case look i reckon i'm 50th
percentile i reckon i'm like slap bang
in the middle of the normal distribution
of normal amount of semen and like quick
as a flash turned to me and you went
95th percentile i'm definitely 95th
percentile i was like and there's a
there's an actual curve for that
somewhere probably fine probably
and i was like look
what so what's it like what's what's
being 95th percentile
come distributor like
and he was like
frankly
a little
but
bit
inconvenient
like okay well what tells you given the
fact that you probably have as much
information about other men's semen
volume as i do
what gives you the impression that you
are 95th percentile and he's like well
every single girl that i'm with
looks down and goes
that's a lot of [ __ ]
and i'm like well yeah i don't know so
just fyi there are there are people out
there that maybe break
a couple of tablespoons it's it's
possible that it's like highly diluted
though you know it's like when you make
yourself a smoothie and it's got way too
much ice in it not enough of the good
stuff
you know
i don't think the volume counts as much
as the millions of sperm that are in the
teeniest tiniest amount so it doesn't
matter anyways oh so you're saying that
you could have like a a dark matter
anti-gravity version of this that is
just unbelievably dense it would be the
size of a pinhead but it would sink
through the bed
it's quality over quantity it's like
when you bite into a hershey's chocolate
bar versus the darkest hundred percent
cacao from the amazon you need a a lot
less of the latter that's that's that's
my opinion at least so that's a bit
awkward talking about eating chocolate
and
sperm volume simultaneously
so uh so so we can move on to a few of
the other things that you know the the
thing i guess that caught the most
attention from that whole protocol was
of course the idea of getting your dick
injected and so i i did a few different
things the first thing i did was what's
called a gains wave treatment where they
take
they use what's called acoustic
acoustic shock wave therapy
uh and what you do is you go into the
clinic and there's a bunch of these all
over the u.s and you walk in uh you've
been evaluated beforehand accepted as a
new patient
uh the nurse hands you a little bottle
of numbing cream with instructions to go
into the bathroom and apply this numbing
cream all over your genitals which which
i i did i
if someone tells me put numbing cream on
my genitals i'm usually gonna do it just
because i suspect whatever comes
afterwards i might need the numbing
cream on hand for them not one of those
guys to like grip my teeth through
through something that my penis needs to
be numbed for i just
so
i uh i put it on and then i go into
the room and
i
the the girl that did it like i did this
in miami she was kind of like a hot
cuban so it was a touch awkward for me
just because i have this lady with this
giant wand like a jack camera going
all over my crotch and i'm like draped
so i can't see my crotch but i can feel
everything going on down there i have no
clue if i've got a boner because
everything's numb and so
um she finishes takes like 20 minutes
and uh it's kind of like ultrasound
supposedly it breaks up old blood
vessels in your penis and women can do
this too as a matter of fact my wife did
it a few times and uh and builds new
blood vessels and so
uh then what they'll do
for the full meal deal is they do the p
shot afterwards for women they call it
the o shot and they take platelet-rich
plasma which is an extract of your own
blood that's been centrifuged and spun
in the centrifuge to concentrate the
growth factors which are then injected
into the penis either before or after
the acoustic shockwave therapy so i did
that protocol
and
the
funniest thing about it was i had dinner
with my grandma scheduled that night
because my grandma lives in miami i
wasn't gonna go to miami and not see my
grandma because i'd be in the dog house
if i did that and so we went out to this
cuban restaurant and this was like five
or six hours after the protocol had been
completed and it was about then that the
numbing cream started to wear off and it
was like
boner institute like literally like i'm
i'm popping a ten right there underneath
the table sitting and having dinner with
my grandma and also my aunt was there my
uh
cindy and my grandma rose are sitting
there as i'm you know eating these
plantain fries and trying to hide the
fact that i've got a raging boner and it
lasted like the whole night not like not
like go to the hospital priapism you
know had too much viagra type of thing
but it's like it was very engorged and i
couldn't wait to get home to my wife and
the effects of that lasted for a solid
i did not intend that pun um
for a solid couple of months and so that
actually really worked and like those
clinics still exist and they even sell
like an at-home device called the rocket
now that you can do the same thing with
at home that's not quite as intense so
you don't need the numbing cream have
you got any idea yeah you can calm the
injection yourself yeah how much of that
was contributed to by the
the plate the rich plasma and how much
was from the i don't think a lot of it
was the rich plasma because i did that
protocol like six times and
i think three or four of them they
didn't do the injection and it seemed
like the results were just as good and i
have the at-home device as well i've
messed around with a little bit it just
seems to work so
yeah and it's very very simple concepts
just like ultrasound breaking up blood
vessels and introducing new blood flow
so there's there's some science behind
it and then like the
i guess the cherry on the cupcake was
the stem cell injection into my penis
which actually i had to prepare for
because when i did it um
you know the stem cell was still a
little bit of wild wild west and i went
to american cell technologies in florida
which was actually rated by the fda
the
day after i got the protocol done i
actually checked this week and my stem
cells are still stored down there
but they have to take your stem cells
and suck them out of your fat
and i'm a pretty skinny ass guy so it
was like violent liposuction one like in
and out of my back you know i felt like
somebody was stabbing me over and over
and over again to extract enough fat for
them to be able to grow my stem cells
which is now illegal in the u.s which is
probably one reason that they had the
fda raid but they expand the stem cells
from your own tissues called autologous
stem cell expansion this is why some
people go to tijuana and places like
that now to get their stem cells because
they can expand them overseas they can't
in the u.s they now combine them with
something called exosomes in the u.s
which arguably makes the stem cells just
as good as if they were expanded but
they didn't have much of that technology
when i did it so
they're expanding the stem cells but
they gotta expand them for two or three
months to get enough of what's called a
mesenchymal stem cell count msc count to
allow them to be worth like re-injecting
back into the body so i actually have my
stem cells from my bone marrow and my
hips stored at forever labs in berkeley
california from when i was 30 years old
and i've got all of my fat stem cells
stored at american cell technologies in
florida from when i was i think 34 35 so
if i ever get in a horrific car accident
or i need a major surgery or something
like that it is kind of cool because i
can actually use my own body stem cells
rather than like embryonic or umbilical
or placental stem cells to help with
recovery but in this case they expand
the fat cells and then
about two months later i had them
shipped up on dry ice to spokane
washington my hometown where i went to
the office of uh dr leno
who's whose son actually there became a
friend of mine he's coming over for
steaks tomorrow night speaking of the
devil and uh
his his dad had never done
this
procedure before so admittedly i was a
little bit nervous but it basically
involved
injecting the corpus callosum of the
penis
on either side like the spongy tissue of
the penis with
like um the equivalent like kind of um
you know a nerve block a numbing age and
again back to the numbing agent and then
injecting in three different spots
my penis with my own stem cells
and
i was kind of
concerned because for like three days my
dick was purple and black and blue and
looked like it been run over by a semi
truck my wife was obviously a little bit
concerned as well
uh you know with with me
experimenting with these fringe
protocols on my genitals and and them
looking
pretty pretty bad after the fact but
that
like if the prp and and chocolate
therapy thing lasted a couple months
like the stem cell thing
i feel like
i've been on cloud nine since so and and
and i have to clarify i've done it twice
since then so i've done a total of three
stem cell injections into my penis and
every time it seems like it gives me a
solid like two years of
amazing boners and my orgasms last like
two or three minutes sometimes and i
have no clue if i'm in the 95th
percentile for [ __ ] production i don't
pay attention to that but it feels like
it just kind of keeps on coming out and
coming out and so there's there's
something going on with the stem cell
injection i don't think that's
you know like my necklace super wu and
placebo like i can guarantee and again
like i'm 40. you know i technically on
paper should not be performing like i'm
18 but i feel like i've got better sex
longer orgasms and a harder dick than i
did when i was a teenager
and you know i'm not financially
affiliated with any stem cell companies
or anything like that it's not a doctor
selling this stuff i just i can say like
it seemed to work so
i think that was the best part of that
whole protocol the new year new dick
thing was the stem cells
what mechanism do you think these stem
cells are working on like what what is
it that causes orgasms to last longer
[Music]
probably all the dick cancer i have i
suspect
just all those little foreign molecules
make an extra baby uh
that actually is the one concern that i
so i had i'm like well i'm injecting
technically a growth medium
into a gland a major gland of my body
and one of the definitions of cancer is
undifferentiated cell growth but yet i i
don't i don't get people think i cowboy
everything in my body there's actually a
lot of literature on what's called
peyronie's disease which is an abnormal
curvature of the penis and also ed or
erectile dysfunction and the use of stem
cells in both those cases had been used
for like five or six years prior to when
i did the protocol with nobody getting
cancer or having ill effects or anything
like that so i was pretty comfortable
with it i
suspect the mechanism of action
is
restoration of more youthful tissue
um you know cleanup of old dead tissue
probably an increase in the activity of
what are called the latex cells in the
testes which which help to produce sperm
and testosterone things like that you
know you know at the same time you got
to remember like as a part of this
magazine article i did the shockwave
therapy
i did like like i have this red light
beside me right and i still do like the
red light naked in the morning every day
which actually has some good data behind
it for testosterone production and it's
also really good for blood flow
um
you know i
started to pay more attention to
a lot of the the foods like like ginseng
and ginger and avocados and a lot of
these things that seem to also help out
with men's sexual health so i had
stacked a lot of stuff
but at the same time it was like when i
got the stem cells within three days it
was like whoa so something's going on
here so there's probably multiple
mechanisms of action uh and i could
hypothesize all day long about what else
is going on but you know stem cells i
mean they're cool i i think that um
despite them often
i think being overpriced or the
mesenchymal stem cell count that you get
if you get injected with them in the u.s
whether it's for a joint for anti-aging
or whatever tends to be a lot lower than
what you get overseas i don't think a
lot of doctors really do a good job with
things like ultrasound guided imaging
when they inject a joint just versus
just kind of randomly putting it where
it seems to hurt like they're you know
it's again still the wild wild west but
i'm a fan of stem cells like i do think
they're good for for regenerative
medicine i think they're good for
longevity i just think
the
uh
the mechanism view which they're
delivered and what they're combined with
is
super important and what i mean by that
again is if you're getting stem cells in
the u.s
ideally they're from your own tissue and
if not from really really good screened
tissue like warton's jelly from the
umbilical area or or placental stem
cells and
then ideally they're also combined with
exosomes which are the tiny signaling
molecules that stem cells use to
communicate with one another and they're
ideally delivered using some form of
ultrasound guided imaging so they get
into the area they're supposed to get
into unless you're just doing an iv for
general anti-aging so so yeah i think
that there's something to them though
that's very interesting to me because
i've got a call with a company out in
colombia it looks like i might be going
out there to get some stem cell
treatment from them and also i mean ohio
or south america south america
okay
and um i mean i'd go to ohio if i was
you i think it's a lot more fun than
south america
it's just me as long as i can fly over
the top of all of the gangs with burning
cars in the middle of the street in
mexico at the moment i think i should be
at least on a a good head start but yeah
they've been going through all of the
different elements of this it's
wharton's jelly from
umbilical cord it's from screen space
blah blah blah it's cultured but all
this sort of stuff um
yeah so it's it's something i hadn't
really considered much before but yeah
they're saying about uh ultrasound
guided some of the work that i would get
done would be intradiscal injections um
yeah two bulging discs or two two discs
that have have lost height uh plus stuff
for um
mental i guess sharpness and agility
i had a achilles rupture two years ago
they still want to go into that they
want to go into my shoulder and they
want to do an iv as well and then you go
into a hyperbaric chamber afterwards
there's a bunch of other stuff that you
go into so it seems it seems pretty it
sounds like they're doing it the right
way there's there's a guy in the us who
does something like that in park city
utah's name is dr harry adelson and he
has this thing called the full body stem
cell makeover
there's a couple videos on youtube
somewhere because i i had him run the
camera while they were doing it on me
and he literally like puts you under a
form of anesthesia and knocks you off
like four hours and does like head to
toe every single joint in your body but
what they're probably using in in
colombia is expanded stem cells because
again he can't do that in the u.s he
like pops into your bone marrow like in
your hips i still have scars on the
other side of my hip and just pulls the
marrow out of your hips and uses like
this bone marrow stem cell soup of your
own cells for the injection so
he does something kind of like that and
usually we'll do like nad ivs and
different cocktails beforehand to kind
of prepare the body i tell people who
are going to travel internationally to
do it though you're going to go
internationally to do stem cells
understand that international travel
itself can be kind of hard on the body
and ideally if you're going to get stem
cells you want your body in as low a
state of inflammation as possible it's
like you know arrive you know three to
four days early maybe try to do a little
bit of hyperbaric beforehand you know do
anti-inflammatory stuff get a good night
of sleep you know take your ginger and
your curcumin and if they have an nadiv
get that kind of stuff so like do a lot
of tlc beforehand so your body's a
little more primed to use the stem cells
i'll be texting you for the protocol
before i uh before i go and do anything
in any case uh going back to what you
were talking about this obviously
sex is only one part of a relationship
and as somebody that looks at
strategies for optimizing different
things have you got principles that you
follow when it comes to maintaining a
healthy relationship with your wife
you've said that you're married for 20
years which you know is a hell of a long
time four kids now three kids four kids
uh you know
two kids two kids
we're kind of thinking about adopting
another kid right now actually we were
talking about that last night but right
now two kids um
and
really i think the main thing it comes
down to chris
is his and hers towels
like you got to have the rack and it's
got to be marked his and hers
the bathrobe's not quite as necessary
but the his and hers towels are pretty
important um besides that
the
the main things
that i think hold us together in our
relationship
is when it comes to
daily check-ins and daily habits we have
two things the first is that as a family
we gather for
family meditation
breath work
tapping prayer and singing both in the
morning and in the evening every day so
i get up usually about 4 35 a.m i get a
bunch of work done i have my own kind of
like spiritual fitness time where i'm
reading my bible i'm praying i'm
listening to really good music typically
burning some incense doing a little
breath work
and um you know then i'll go do some
stretching and foam rolling and stuff
get a couple hours of riding and work
done and then by then my family's
awake and i gather the family it's
usually about 7 30. i pop upstairs to
the living room from my office and
usually i'll tell everybody hey five
minute warning you know me on the back
porch or on the patio and you know the
whole family will gather some meditation
cushions you know old journal we use one
called the spiritual disciplines journal
and we gather
about 7 30
we
go into meditation breathing uh play
some nice background music i actually
like to use insight timer as a
meditation timer just because
my selection right now is the angelic
choir voices so
instantly transported to the clouds of
heaven with the harps and and the choir
and we play that and i have it set for
about eight minute meditation so for the
first three minutes we're just basically
settling in you know and that could be
your own private time of prayer that
could be you doing some breath work it
could be uh there's like a little bible
verse on the top of each page that we
meditate with
and i might what i do during that time
is i try to memorize the bible verse so
i'm memorizing some good proverb or
something every day of the week and a
lot of times my sons are doing that and
then there's a little timer that goes
off little bell that goes off at the
three minute mark at that point we go
into gratitude so it's two minutes of
writing down what it is that you're
grateful for and then as you're no doubt
aware like reimagining and
reliving that experience in your mind so
the same neurotransmitters and hormones
and chemicals and feel goodness kind of
rushes over you
that's the same as you may have
experienced when you had that moment of
gratitude occur in the first place so
two minutes of writing down what it is
we're grateful for thinking about that
gratefulness praying uh prayer of thanks
for that thing that happened to us or
that person we encountered and then the
bell goes off and the last thing we do
is service so i think a lot of mourning
practices are based on self-affirmation
like you know like who does uh stuart
smalling
saturday night live like i'm good i'm
wonderful gosh darn people like me and
me me me we instead have a more others
facing approach yeah so we write down
one person we can pray for or help or
serve and then we got two minutes to
like plan that out right to
make our grand master plan for how we're
going to help that person that day or
maybe we can't we're just going to like
pray for them during that time send
positive emotions their way but one
person every day it's 365 days you've
got one person you're really going out
of your way to sacrifice for or help or
serve and then we finish after the final
bell goes off at the eight minute mark
with about 20 seconds of tapping just
based on neuro-linguistic programming
we'll set an anchor that when it gets
stressful later on in the day and we tap
in that same location we've trained the
body to go into that same state of peace
and rest that we were in at the end of
the meditation that morning
uh we all take a deep breath in just one
giant
and then out release a sigh we'll
typically say a prayer
and then we do like a team huddle you
know literally a team hunter like
everybody comes together yo what's for
dinner uh what time is dinner who's
cooking this who's cooking that what
time is jiu jitsu when are you guys
going to tennis when's dad gonna go play
pickleball you know what time are we are
we starting this and that and so it's
basically like a five-minute team huddle
where we're just all getting on the same
page then you know boom and we're off
and if we don't see each other the whole
day like we're like chips passing the
night and we usually do see each other
during the day because i work from home
my sons are unschooled my wife's a
domestic engineer taking care of the
goats and chickens and stuff like that
so we're kind of together but separate
most of the day
and then at the end of the day we have a
giant
dinner party every night at our house
it's like a giant party like we
literally can meet in the kitchen at
seven and we cook an amazing meal and
we'll sing songs and play the guitar and
then bust out a game
and literally just like play games for
an hour hour and a half when we stuff
our faces and we all clean together and
then we go up to my son's room and i'll
play some guitar i'll read them a story
and then we finish with meditation and
that evening meditation is basically
self-examination
uh you know an ancient practice that's
super useful for stacking each day and
making each day consecutively better and
for that we literally watch ourselves
live our entire day like
we're watching a character in a movie
you know in the third person and as
you're watching that character of you in
the movie of your day
which is something you can get better
and better at like i can literally play
out my whole day in 60 90 seconds now
like what i do when i woke up what i
have for breakfast who'd i talk to you
know what [ __ ] did i podcast with
who are drinking fake soda what do i
have for lunch and what i do in the
afternoon how's my workout so on and so
forth and then you're asking yourself
three questions what
good did i do this day
what could i have done better this day
or what did i fail at that i don't want
to repeat tomorrow and then where was i
most purpose-filled this day
and those three questions not only help
you to identify those areas where you're
really contributing to the world
those things that you don't want to
repeat or fail at because
as you know how we live our days is how
we live our life so examining each day
really really helps make each day
consecutively better and then the
purpose-filled one i think is the best
one because
it's kind of surprising sometimes the
things you're doing where you actually
were happy and time was flying by and
you felt like you were using your unique
skill set and the things that you
realize are not serving you or you
should be delegating or outsourcing
because they don't feel that purpose
filled right like whatever you know i
used to i used to write all my social
media posts right and and i never once
wrote down that that felt purpose
filling you know in my journal for me
purposes
doing a podcast or writing an article
and then something surprised like i feel
purpose-filled when i'm cooking a meal
for my family i feel purpose-filled when
i'm writing a song on the guitar right
like so and there's some stuff that that
come up in your journal that surprise
you you know sometimes it's not
something that that's monetizable or
part of your business so you know that's
kind of like the ikigai purpose part of
the day and uh you know then and that
whole time we're doing breath work and
then we finish i say goodnight to the
kids i and we go to bed um
so i would say that
in addition to that
kind of bookending of the day which is
obviously not just my wife and i you
know you're asking about relationships
it's more like a familial thing the two
other things that come to mind is
every night the last thing we do before
our eyes close and we fall asleep
is my wife and i pray together
a lot of times it's literally just like
words slipping out of our mouth as our
eyelids are fluttering and we're falling
asleep it's the very last thing we do
i can tell you that this kind of
surprised me because i heard a lot of
couples who were married for a long time
prayed together every night before they
went to bed and i thought oh this makes
sense kinda you know it's like you just
have some routine that you're relying on
and some touch point uh i wasn't
convinced it had to be a prayer
but then i realized it's really hard
to be spiritually yoked or like talk to
a higher power or commune with the
divine together
if there's something some rarest between
you right some argument you've had that
on something that's between you and
you'll pray and you'll feel like oh geez
something's like fake and awkward here
and so
it almost forces you to make sure
everything's set right before you go to
bed because you know the very last thing
coming up is praying and you don't want
to be fake you want to be real and you
want your heart to be pure
so we pray every night before you go to
bed and then
once
or tw or sorry once a quarter or
at the least
once every half year
my wife and i
go somewhere for
two to three days sometimes it's a
staycation sometimes it's
sometimes it's going to an exotic locale
sometimes driving to a town two hours
from our house and checking into a
roadside motel
but we will go and lock ourselves away
and
we will talk we will journal we will
plan out the next year you know
not not only you know do we want to live
here are we going to move uh what do we
feel about the kids education right now
what are things i'm doing that i need to
stop doing what are things you're doing
that annoy me about you just everything
laid out on the table like truth serum
now i have to admit that we started that
process
um
about seven years ago and we started
that process with drugs so we would go
take mdma
or
we would um you know do like a sassafras
or some other heart opener or you know
microdose together or just basically
be in a different space mentally merge
left and right brain hemispheres sit
together facing each other in bed and
these little chairs called back jack
chairs you know legs intertwined
sometimes for six to eight hours talking
we'd have recorders on the whole time
recording everything we said so we could
play it back and transcribe it now we
don't even need
it's almost as though after you've done
mdma a few times with your love or
something like that it's such a hard
opener and you realize that you can be
transparent and tell the truth
no matter what even without a substance
in your system so now it's it's kind of
cool we'll just go off you know
sometimes we'll go out to dinner i have
a glass of wine whatever but those
quarterly retreats those quarterly touch
points that are intentional and built
for family planning for coming together
for checking in with each other on a
much deeper level than we might on a
random date night are i think super
critical to our relationship success
it seems like a lot of the things are
trying to find a common thread between
the stuff that's came up for you there
is
unearthing or not allowing
um
malignant
ideas or unspoken concerns or emotions
or feelings to burble under the surface
without actually verbalizing them
whether that be as a part of the family
whether that be between you and your
wife
uh i had seth stevens davidowitz on and
he's this data scientist right but he
has this great little
quote where he talks about how we often
mistake a familiar or comfortable
activity for a valuable one and it's
kind of the same when you think about
life as well that there are things that
you do just because they're routine
there are thought patterns that you have
just because they're routine or because
they're comfortable maybe it's always
hitting snooze maybe it's always giving
yourself a cookie after a meal maybe
it's whatever and without the ability to
step back measuring your thumb
measuring your [ __ ] with tablespoons
if you don't give yourself the ability
to step back and actually observe that
and say look do i need to continue
measuring my [ __ ]
should i be doing this in front of other
people should i be bringing you up in a
pool in dubai
you never actually check in and realize
like this this is maybe something that i
need to so i love the idea i love the
idea of stepping back a little bit um
that's cool man i really really like
yeah
yeah and it's
we have this this rule of radical
honesty and transparency in our home
there are obviously tons of values one
could have as an individual as a family
but we spent some time a couple of years
ago mapping out our key family values
and forming not only a family mission
statement but like a family crest like
literally like an old school medieval
style crest that says dynasty [ __ ] hangs
above our fireplace dynasty legacy
family logo that's on
you know the coasters and the throw
pillows and these you know two flags on
either side of our front door when you
come up it's like a freaking like a lego
castle with the with the greenfield
family logo flying we've got like a
hundred page document that's the
greenfield family playbook what do we do
on thanksgiving what are we doing
christmas what do we do when the kids
are eight when's the birds and the beast
talk happen when did they do their rite
of passage into adolescence when they do
their vision quest and rite of passage
into adulthood when are they quit
getting money from mom and dad when do
they go on a service trip overseas
that's that's entirely other faced um
what is the family mission statement and
what does each element of the crest
represent
my 14 year boys already you know based
on the concept of memento mori have
their entire death planned out they have
their funeral arranged they have their
memorial service planned out everything
is in this book from end of life wishes
to family traditions to family mission
statements the family values to the
family crest all the way down to each of
our individual family hex color logo and
font type and spirit animal
brand
yeah it's a branding guide for the
greenfield family when my kids have kids
when they move out of the house i'll be
able to just hand them this book
they can take it they can run with it
they can improve on it i think it's one
of the best ways to
kind of counteract that rags to riches
to rags phenomenon that's all too common
where slow erosion of all of the good
wisdom that you accumulated yeah
yeah yeah what do they say uh he
you might have to help me out with this
one chris because i don't remember it's
a what is it hard men make good times
good times make soft men's sauce
or something like that yeah and it's
kind of based on that concept of
continually improving
generationally as a family
from a legacy standpoint rather than
simply having things slowly degrade
because there is no tradition there is
no built-in playbook i mean you know of
course we have a family bank too every
single member of our family has a whole
life insurance policy they have paid up
cash editions every month we literally
have hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of dollars for each family member socked
away that any of us
can borrow against using ourselves as a
bank basically that money that we've
borrowed can stay in the account being
invested for whatever it needs to be
invested for but i can borrow money
against myself at a very similar rate as
i might be able to get competitively
from a credit union and that money
the reason that i think it's more
valuable is because it's going into an
insurance policy so even if my
interest rate i'm getting on my loan
from myself might not be necessarily
lower than i get from a bank or credit
union i've also got this massive cash
policy if i die so there's like that
protection component worked in for for
me for my wife for our kids so that
family banking concept is is really
really cool too and that's that's just
built in as part of the greenfield
family constitution you know that's what
so a lot of families who pass on general
relational wealth that's that's one
thing that they'll use as a tool to do
so yeah i think that you're right there
there's definitely something interesting
about people no longer living
usually with parents or near parents
uh definitely not near grandparents you
know most people most kids at the age of
18 22 something like that they want to
fly the nest but that ancestrally
wouldn't have been the way that we would
have typically lived it would have been
a pan generational household it would
have been multiple generations of the
same family with extended families and
second cousins blah blah blah all living
under one
tribe one roof maybe even in some
situations one blanket you know before
we develop clothes and i think sitting
out on the sitting on the front porch
playing the banjo with your cousin who
you just married totally man speak for
yourself so look um one other thing that
i've been considering a lot recently is
um
the difference between training for
aesthetics and training for health and
longevity and i think that if people
haven't spent a little bit of time
considering it that those two things can
often get confused that people can think
i go to the gym i do a push-pull leg
split i make sure that i eat one gram of
protein per pound of body weight per day
i am
i am doing both health and fitness and
longevity and looking good all together
but
what i mean this is
going from your background someone that
did bodybuilding someone that did
endurance racing and triathlons and
stuff like that
what are the biggest changes or what are
the um biggest holes in training
protocols
that guys and girls that go to the gym
to train for aesthetics are missing
if they want to benefit their health
what should they add in if they want to
benefit longevity alongside the way that
they look
yeah i would say that probably
in addition to your question would be
that training for aesthetics slash
performance is not synonymous with
health right so it's kind of both
because some people are who are doing
crossfit or spartan racing or ironman
triathlon and i experienced a lot of
this myself racing
20 years in iron man and you know four
years and sperm racing
uh fitness and athleticism are not
necessarily synonymous with health with
fertility with longevity and often you
know paradoxically to some people
fly in the face of those values
uh and so you know if you decide you're
gonna like get fit and do an iron man
triathlon you know don't convince
yourself that it's healthy you're gonna
be fit you're gonna look good in spandex
you're gonna be able to go for hours on
a bicycle and stare at the black line at
the bottom of the pool for a really long
time
but if your experience is anything like
the thousands of people i've seen doing
this when i look at the blood and
biomarkers of these folks you have
thyroid dysregulation and
you know endocrine system dysregulation
and hypogonadism in males and you know
amenorrhea and females and low bone
density and rampant levels of
inflammation and ironically like
pre-type 2 diabetes in many of these
folks sometimes based on their diet
sometimes based on the stress component
so yeah it's definitely an issue i think
the
main things
that
the majority of the fitness world in
particular needs to understand
let me think here if i could boil it
down to a few principles
a the human body is innately good at
endurance and aerobic based activity
given proper amounts of food and water
we can outlast any animal on the planet
humans have outrun horses for example in
100 mile races and you know in the
mountains in the west and we can go and
go and go
there's very little need to train
yourself with chronic cardio and
mid-level aerobic activity
for long periods of time at all i tell
most people one session a week you know
where you're going out on maybe a hike
where you're where you're sucking air
just a little bit more or a bike ride to
a neighboring town or a coffee shop or a
long swim or something like that you
really only need to touch endurance once
a week max and
fewer people in the
kind of like meat heady part of fitness
do this but still it's a big thing in
endurance sports people are doing
way too much time with just like chronic
repetitive cardio the only type of
chronic repetitive cardio you should be
doing is walking would that be zone 2
would you be does that mean that you're
not a fan of zone 2 cardio for people to
spend whatever 180 minutes a week
zone 2 cardio
would be like the ancestral activity of
hunting all day long or me walking on
the treadmill while i'm talking to you
it's obviously conversational i'm not
sucking air yep a lot of people think
they're zone two and
they're way above it and they're what i
would consider i wrote a book about this
called beyond training they're in what's
called no man's land for their training
zone hard enough to where you're not
getting super fit uh or or not so hard
that you're getting super fit but hard
enough to where you're draining your
body without much points like junk
training basically so most people think
they're aerobic when you see them
jogging down the side of the road with a
with a poopy face on you know in the
heat with their fuel belts strapped
around their waist now most of the time
like again unless you're training for
iron man triathlon and you've accepted
the fact that okay i'm trading in my
health for performance because i want to
cross the finish line of this mount
everest i built for myself fine like
just don't commit yourself to getting
healthy probably not you produce
arterial stiffness and inflammation and
you know heart disease and ventricular
hypertrophy and a whole host of factors
that take it's not healthy so yes on
zone 2 but for most people they don't
really understand that zone 2 is
literally like easy walk in the sunshine
with your dog right or maybe it's a
little bit of yoga in the sauna or
something like that so the majority of
your training should be super easy or
super hard right so when you get in you
just drain yourself so like my workout
this morning in the weights was one took
me 20 minutes one single set the failure
for deadlift
chest press
pull down
squat
overhead press and row each set took me
about three minutes right so a lot of
time under tension
and you just go bam bam bam bam bang it
out and that's my strength training
session i'm going balls out the whole
time but i'm not i'm not sitting around
at all right and the same thing for
actual cardio training like my cardio
workout yesterday was i had a little
like oxygen restriction device on it was
30 seconds easy 30 seconds hard for 20
minutes on the air dime and it sucked
ass the whole time right but when you're
done you're done so that's my philosophy
go hard when you should go hard and then
everything else is just like hyper hyper
easy low level physical activity
throughout the day
now
that being said
i think that in addition to
excesses of endurance or
when you do your strength training and
your high testing interval training
going for too long at a medium level
intensity versus just going balls out
and being done
the the other mistakes that people make
is
not understanding that the human body
is basically like a giant battery each
of the cells operate at a precise
electrochemical gradient across the cell
membrane
there are books about this like the body
electric
by
robert becker or healing is voltage by
jerry tennant and
the idea that your body is very
electrically tuned
is something
that is largely ignored in
context of modern fitness and health
advice like men's health magazine or
women's health magazine or whatever like
they're establishing that fitness is
important and movement is important and
healthy movement is important they do a
pretty good job doing that
a lot of them also have established
somewhat healthy eating patterns where
like eat naturally as close to the earth
as possible trade in the diet dr pepper
for foofy overpriced stevia water uh you
know um you know eat
adequate amounts of protein eat healthy
fats he knows the tail meats like it's
not rocket science to like eat more like
our ancestors and avoid fake [ __ ] right
and and i i could tell you this stuff
but that's a giant echo chamber of
advice and the whole nutrition
podcasting sector everybody kind of
knows this stuff
it's going to vary from person to person
but let's say you are eating well
and you're moving well
when it comes to treating your body like
a batter that's not enough there are
other things that you can do and i think
that the most important things would be
contact with the surface of the earth on
a regular basis
because you get this natural
anti-inflammatory magnetic frequency
that's emitted by the surface of the
planet every time lightning strikes the
earth it collects
negative ions and these are then
absorbed by your body when you're
outside barefoot when you're
down there in austin swimming in barton
springs when you're climbing a tree when
you're rock climbing whatever most
humans don't touch our planet enough and
there are books about this like the book
earthing that has some really
interesting data on how much that lowers
inflammation regulates circadian rhythm
improves mood improves performance
improves cellular health and longevity
so i think most people need to be from a
fitness standpoint touching the planet
more how long
how often
well 20 minutes or two hours a day if
you can i mean i have a map that i sleep
on all night long because there's this
there's this field of
health technology called pulsed
electromagnetic field therapy pemf
therapy and you can literally get mats
in your office that are earthing your
grounding mats or pmf mats you can sleep
all night so you can kind of turn your
home into the equivalent of what you'd
be absorbing if you were in a cave even
if you're on like the the you know 60th
floor of a skyscraper downtown you can
kind of like pull the earth into you
using technology as well because a lot
of these will plug into the grounding
outlet of your
living space or they will with a
controller create a frequency of
anywhere from three to a hundred hertz
which is similar to what the earth
naturally emits so
there's that
photons of light are also super
important for that electrical component
because they're what excite the
electrically charged molecules that are
traveling through your body that's why
there's a lot of data behind
the
health benefits of things like
near-infrared farm for red and red light
in moderation
uva and uvb radiation from sunlight
um
you know the use of even things like
like head gear that produces red lights
and and things like that for control of
alzheimer's and dementia and activating
parts of the mitochondria that are in
neural tissue you know a while back we
mentioned red light you know on the
testes and that does actually increase
the activity of the latex cells and the
testes helps to produce testosterone
like we are meant to be light creatures
you know like light eaters like
collectors the human body is kind of
like a plant in that context which is
crazy because like if you consume
chlorella or like methylene blue or
spirulina or any dark green or bluish
compound and go out in the sun you get
an even increased activity of a lot of
this mitochondrial upregulation so your
body does have a little bit like this
plant-esque aspect to it so number two
would be light um which again a lot of
people in the fitness system are like
they're indoors and gyms and not getting
earthing and light i think that um and
i'm glad that this is catching on now
most people did not subject themselves
to extremes of temperature enough
extremes of heat and extremes of cold a
robust sauna practice is a deep sweat
four to five times a week 20 to 45
minutes be a barrel sauna it could be an
infrared sauna well
it could be a barrel stone with infrared
lights in it well barrel sounds gonna be
high like 190 to 200. my i have an
infrared and it goes up to like 156 and
because infrared
light kind of penetrates the tissue
you got to be in there a little bit
longer preheat preheated a little bit
longer but i can get just as deep of
sweat and infrared as i can in a barrel
sauna
the only one i would be careful with is
a steam sauna unless you know the source
of the water and whether or not the room
is regularly checked for mold because
you don't want to be breathing into your
lungs the steam from water that's got
like you know chlorine and birth control
chemicals and pharmaceuticals and all
the stuff that collects in the municipal
water supply
unless that's your jam you don't want to
be breathing that in when you're in a
steam sauna so a lot of times like just
ask the health club hey you have a water
filter here and you know if you know if
it's connected to the to the water that
goes in the same sun if nobody knows i'm
i'm pretty careful with steam sauna but
barrel or infrared um
so much data behind the benefits of that
for cellular resilience and blood sugar
control and cardiovascular health and
the same could be said for cold like
daily cold soak most of the data shows
that you can either do shorter periods
of time but very cold which is what i do
i have a cold tub right outside the door
here 10 feet from here right now i keep
at 33 degrees i get in there for one to
two minutes a couple times a day you
could also do longer soaks it's got to
be at least 55 degrees and cold water
immersion is better than cryotherapy
chambers because of the hydrostatic
pressure for the water
against the skin and the fact that your
head gets wet and both of those allow
for either a decrease in core
temperature that's more significant or
an activation of the vagus nerve which
is really good for your central nervous
system in response to cold
so
heat and cold preferably cold water
immersion really important and then the
last things i think that people in the
fitness world forget and again all this
is related to treating your body in
terms of increasing its electrical
conductivity
uh would be
good clean pure water preferably
filtered preferably as close to nature
as possible you know out of glass not
plastic you know for example gold
standard would be you know for a water
filter like double carbon block reverse
osmosis with some type of
remineralization added to it because a
lot of those will strip the minerals
from the water so you add minerals back
into it because those are what charge
the blood but carry the electricity
throughout the blood as charged minerals
so water is something that
kind of well it kind of shocks me i'll
see somebody like do a hard workout and
walk out and just like grab a plastic
bottle of water it was basically like
dead water without minerals in it a lot
of times plastics in it and suck that
down like people don't pay attention
even people who pay attention to food a
lot of times don't pay close enough
attention to water you know i think i'm
probably biased because my dad when i
was growing up was a coffee roaster a
gourmet coffee roaster and he used to
repair espresso machines for a lot of
the coffee shops that he'd worked with
and he found that the major two factors
that affected the flavor of the coffee
were of course the source and quality of
the bean but then also the source and
the quality of the water that was used
in these machines he eventually got out
of the coffee industry and now all he
does is design water filters so i've
learned a ton from him like he imports
this crazy [ __ ] from israel and these
technologies like structure the water
and like i'll go and visit his warehouse
and he's got everything from like
the coolest latest technology that
spiralizes and vortices and mineralizes
the water after it passes through
reverse osmosis and double carbon block
all the way down to like
like icons of saints and holy water from
lords in france and a tiny drop of that
goes into each filter so he's got he's
got it covered from the woo to the
scientific so i've learned a lot about
water from him and the importance of
water after seeing what happens like the
the the cattle at the feedlots that
install these type of water filters or
you know people who use those type of
central water filters house so
water and minerals are important so
coming full circle i would say that if
you're eating well you're moving well
you're not over training you're not
doing chronic cardio you're eating close
to earth treat your body like a battery
and get outside barefoot or use some
kind of earthy and grounding technology
get a ton of exposure to photons of
light get hot a lot get cold a lot
be super picky about your water and add
minerals to your food and add minerals
to your water and you will have a
battery that actually works and that
covers the basis for like 95 percent of
people who are already working out and
eating healthy and feel like they're
still not moving the dial dude i love it
that's really really nice i also agree
that i think it's cool that a lot of the
fitness world is starting to converge on
this sort of thinking um what is the
most convenient or easiest way for
people that think wow i really haven't
considered much to the water that i use
maybe they've got an in-fridge filter
maybe they're using a brita filter at
the moment and they they've considered
that to be enough is that enough and if
not what is enough what's the minimum
viable water
uh approach yeah brit is not that great
minimum viable
i've got no like investment or financial
affiliation with them but there's
there's a guy named robert slovak who's
pretty smart who helped a company called
air doctor develop a countertop reverse
osmosis system
that unlike a lot of countertop reverse
osmosis systems or pitchers
has special coating and special
treatment inside the basin that allows
it not to collect bacteria and mold
which a lot of people don't realize
builds up pretty quickly in countertop
water filters so i'd go with something
like an air doctor i think there's
another very similar one it might even
be the same company called aqua true
like without an e tru
um see you guys mispronounce [ __ ] like
aluminium in the uk and we misspell [ __ ]
like true in the us
but basically
an aqua uh what did i say air air
air doctor an aqua operator air doctor
is the air filter i think the same
company makes that's what i'm thinking
but yeah aqua true um robert's got a
website i think it's water and wellness
and they have those type of air filters
or those type of water filters there um
so that's a pretty good solution and
there's some pretty decent just like
pour through water filters as well um
naturals is is my dad's stuff and he's
got like a pour through water filter
that i'll travel with sometimes
nice okay
final few things
arx owned by mike polano
i've started training with him
out here are you sore
dude that thing is [ __ ] white have
you got one in your house
yeah
i do built different it's crazy it's
like fighting a giant robot i mean look
you you can do things like you know
there's a guy named john jacquish makes
the x3 bar which is kind of similar it's
like single set to failure resistance
training with these super hard core
elastic bands
you can do like a super slow routine set
the failure on nautilus or if you're
more functional with like dumbbells and
free weights but having like
25 freaking horses because that's what
it is it's 25 horsepower engine that
thing like you're basically fighting 25
horses with cables
for the entirety of the set
you know some people will like
trip with magic mushrooms and then look
at psilocybin and say i never want to
touch that [ __ ] again
it's kind of like that when you finish
your workout in the arcs you finish and
you're like i never want to do that [ __ ]
again and then like the sort of subsides
in three or four days you're like i'm
back for more baby it's a great time
hack i like it dude it's so good i'm
very very impressed with what those guys
have done i can't wait until it becomes
a more widespread you know if you could
get one in every airport in the country
and you need to get a 20-minute workout
in
have you used the toenail before
what's that it's like the wall mounted
space saver device
it's got like this eccentric function
it's kind of like it's kind of the air x
but maybe think like one horsepower
instead of 25
but it's like for people who don't want
to spend like fifty thousand bucks on an
exercise machine or hunt one down their
city the toenail actually does a lot of
that like push pull against you type of
stuff that the arx does so that'd be
another kind of like budget option for
folks i would say the tonal or the x3
bar would be the top two ways to kind of
experience what we're talking about
if you don't have access to or don't
spend the money on the machine yeah
eccentric training is just
it's it's absolutely wild it's so
efficient one thing that you brought up
earlier on that you mentioned about was
um some of the different ways that
people can get themselves give
themselves a state change without using
alcohol
what are
i know that you've made a diversion away
from psychedelics and stuff like that
recently
what are some of the ways that you would
say people could perhaps
get themselves a little woozy on an
evening time without dipping into
alcohol
yeah obviously there's all sorts of like
crazy elixirs out there and all these
companies like i don't know kin comes to
mind is one that i'm aware of that has
all these different nootropic and herbal
adaptogenic blends and those like kind
of sort of work it's pretty seldom i
don't run into somebody who doesn't pour
themselves a shot of that over ice and
come back 15 minutes later and be like
hey you got any any rum bro
i need a drink
um
however that being said i think there's
two ways to go when it comes to actually
feeling the socially lubricating and
relaxing kind of like gabaergic effects
of alcohol without the toxic side
effects of all the acetaldehyde and [ __ ]
and i think number one
is this company
that
makes
ketones which are kind of like alcohol
but don't get converted into the same
damaging stuff
it's like a ketone ester one three
butane dial
dangerously close actually to one for
butane dial which is basically uh
gamma hydroxybutyric acid which is you
know the old school ghb so you gotta be
careful with this stuff as a matter of
fact if you combine it with alcohol
you're likely to roof yourself or
whoever you serve the drink to so
proceed with caution but they are
they're made with one three butane dial
they've got a moscow mule flavor they've
got a gin tonic flavor they've got a new
champagne flavor which i honestly
they taste amazingly like champagne
which is super cool
and uh
the
company is called ketone aid
and that stuff works remarkably well
like surprisingly well to feel like
you're on alcohol but again like my
brother came over the house he had a
glass of wine then he had one of those
and like i made amazing steaks and he
was almost face down on the table not
even interested in eating so don't
combine that with alcohol but by itself
amazing
and then the other would be more of a
technology play
there's one company called apollo and
one company called hat b
apollo is a haptic-based wearable that
will simulate the magnetic signature of
there's a few on there like um i like
the one for like socializing at parties
because it was actually designed by an
mdma therapist so that one kind of
simulates mdma um another signal will
simulate caffeine another will simulate
like uh melatonin a relaxation so you
can wear that around your ankle it's
called an apollo and just flip it on and
there's one called social mode and you
can use that as an alternative to
drinking alcohol or in addition drinking
less alcohol and then the other one is
called the half bee
and that one simulates the
magnetic signature of a whole host of
different molecules like caffeine and
thc and nicotine like i had on focus
mode i was working yesterday but it was
called creative focus mode so it was
giving me caffeine plus thc but i didn't
have to like drink a cup of coffee and
smoke a joint while i'm working on an
article it's literally just like doing
it through a magnetic signature then as
soon as you take it off it disappears
and
a lot of people don't seem to feel it
when they first use it i didn't really
notice it much like two weeks and i
think that's based on the process of
what's called entrainment where your
body kind of has to like get used to the
signal and then you just start to soak
it up like i
hope a social worker doesn't wind up on
my door by me saying this but i put it
on alcohol and put it on my son taran at
dinner one night and he just got like
super loopy and hilarious
and then he kind of like got quiet and
started to like slump over in his chair
after dinner and i took it off him and
then he was just fine and so you know
you you can you can using the magic
and wonders of technology get your
children drunk legally uh or use it for
the purposes that you're asking about
chris see i'd say the apollo the hat b
or these ketone aid drinks are all
pretty good for that dude i love it look
ben greenfield ladies and gentlemen
what have you got coming up next what
can people expect over the next year
i'm writing a parenting book a really
big one
it's kind of like tools of titans or
tribe of mentors where i've interviewed
about 30 of the most amazing parents i
know who all have really impactful
children i just like picked their brains
and it's like the hardest book i've ever
written because i'm basically you know
like
sheep herding and and cat herding you
know tons of different parents from
divorced fathers to
you know polyamorous parents to our
polygamous parents to you know single
mothers to
homeschool christian backwoods folks to
you know liberal bay area parents just
like getting everybody's advice and i've
condensed it into this book right now
the manuscript is about 1400 pages so
i'm kind of getting it cut down as i do
with a lot of my books i'm putting the
stuff that i cut because i like to kiss
my babies goodbye on the website for the
book and so that'll live on but the
actual book will be like
kind of like a 650ish page tome on
parenting with some of the best advice
from some of the best parents on the
face of the planet and
that's hopefully going to come out
towards the end of this year and it's
going to be called boundless parenting
so that's it um
i think it's at
boundlessparentingbooks.com right now
dude i love it i really really enjoy
seeing the little arc that you're going
through as well you seem genuinely happy
and fulfilled at the moment which makes
me feel [ __ ] good to bask in the
reflective glow of someone that's got
stuff right so i'm super happy for you
man i appreciate the hell out of you
all right man well go go back to your
[ __ ] measuring and soda drinking
and i'll hold down the ford up here in
washington i'll see you in october i'll
be down there in austin october yes sir
see you soon all right all right later
bro what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]